では
慈悲の瞑想いたします
私は
幸せであり
ますように
私の
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
私の
願い事が
叶えられますように
私に
悟りの光が
現れますように
私は
幸せでありますよう
に私は
これから私は
幸せでありますようにと心の中で
繰り返し
念じてください
私の
親しい
生命が
幸せでありますよう
私の
親しい生命の
悩み
苦しみが
なくなるますように
私の
親しい
生命の
願い事が
叶えられますように
私の
親しい
生命にも
悟りの光が
現れますよう
私の
親しい生命が
幸せでありますように
私の
親しい
生命が
幸せでありますように
私の
親しい
生命が
幸せでありますよう
にはいこれから親しい生命が
幸せでありますようにと
繰り返し
念じます
続けるものが
幸せでありますように
息苦しい行けるものの
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
行けるものの
願い事が
叶えられますように
行けるものにも
悟りの光が
現れますように
幾年行けるものが
幸せでありますように
愛しい行けるものが
幸せであります
[音楽]
行けるものが
幸せでありますように
これから生きとし生けるものが
幸せでありますようにと
繰り返し心の中で
念じます
私の
嫌いな生命が
幸せでありますように
私の
嫌いな生命の
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
皆様こんにちは
日本セラーダム協会の
稲垣潤一と申します今日は1月の
植物を月例講演会にお越しくださいまして
誠にありがとうございます
[音楽]
リピーターの方も
励みになりますのでアンケートにご協力
いただけると大変
嬉しく思いますよろしくお願いします
昨日
の交流会というのはこのご法話の後で皆
さんで
感想とかですね疑問とかをちょっと親しく
お話できたら
楽しいなと思って
企画しているものでございますのでぜひご
参加いただければと思います今日の20時
からございますはい
ZOOMで皆さんで
お話をしたいなと思って
それとあと一番下の初めて参加された方へ
とこういう
紙の一番下にこれは
私も先生がお経を最初に整え役だったん
ですけど皆さんで行いますけどもそのこと
の
意義ということを
初めてだと戸惑う方もいらっしゃるかなと
いうことでちょっと解説をさせていただい
てでございますのでスマホで
読んでいただければと思います
今月
[音楽]
末の7月30日にグァンゴ入り法要が
ございますそれまたホームページなどでも
ご案内いたしますけれどもぜひ確保様が
ここから近く
始業を集中的に取り組む期間ということで
来年も一緒に
診療しましょうという
儀式をお願いする
しその時に合わせて
松井先生に
会長が
先月の
お亡くなりになりました6月の26日東海
が25日だったので総会をお届けるように
してお亡くなりになりました広報料も
これを行うことが決まりましたまだ詳細
決まっておりませんけどもホームページ
などでご案内いたしますのでよろしくお
願いいたします松井さんはいつも
ここでお話し一言皆さんにご挨拶した後は
だいたい
後ろの方で
静かに
見守るようにしてお話をいつも聞いていて
まさにそういう存在でとても
感謝の意味とちょっと心細い
では
よろしくお願いいたします
ご挨拶でしたではまもなく開会となります
のでそのままお待ちください
では
慈悲の瞑想いたします
私は
幸せでありますように
私の
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
私の
願い事が
叶えられますように
私に
悟りの光が
現れますよう
に私は
幸せでありますよう
幸せでありますように
私は
幸せであります
にこれから私は
幸せでありますようにと心の中で
繰り返し
念じてください
私の
[音楽]
生命が
幸せでありますよう
私の親しい
生命の
悩み
苦しみが
なくなるますように
私の
親しい
生命の
願い事が
叶えられますように
私の
親しい
生命にも
悟りの光が
現れますよう
に
すいませんちょっと車が混んでると
少々お待ちください
分断されないがちゃに
ドラマそれなんかチャーム
洗顔されなく
[音楽]
Bさんがそれなんか
エルマに
しかダンスまで
[音楽]
にしか
バダン様でやみ
[音楽]
では
慈悲のメッセージいたします
私は
幸せでありますよう
私の
[音楽]
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますね
私
の
願い事が
叶えられますように
私に
悟りの光が
あられますね
私は
幸せでありますよう
に私が
に私は
幸せであります
[音楽]
私は幸せでありますようにと繰り返し
念じます
私の
親しみが
[音楽]
幸せでありますよう
に
私の
親しい
生命の
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますよう
私
の
親しい
生命の
願い事が
叶えられますように
私の
親しい
生命にも
悟りの光が
現れますね
私
の
親しい
生命が
幸せでありますように
私の
親しい
生命が
幸せであります
ように
私の
生命が
幸せであります
親しい生命が幸せでありますようにと
繰り返し
念じます
生き
てけるものが
幸せでありますように
生きとしてるものの
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますね
願い事が
叶えられませんように
生きていけるものにも
悟りの光が
現れませんよう
ものが
幸せでありますように
生き
てけるものが
幸せにありますね
[音楽]
幸せであります
生きとしているものが幸せでありますよう
にと
繰り返し
念じます
生きとしけるものが
幸せでありますように
息吹き出してるものが
幸せであります
ように
生きざし行けるものが
幸せでありますね
はいありがとうございます
ではよろしくお願いします
今日
法話会のねお布施をなさった方々4名様で
ございます
心から
仏法僧の生まれありますように
ということで感謝の言葉も申し上げたいん
です
まあ教えてのマットの中でも法制という
ことが大変大事な
お店になります
ブッダの真理は
人類が知った方がよろしいんですねです
からこれ真理を広げるためのお布施です
から
人類に対してのお星になりますだから多大
な
効果結果になる
功徳になる行為ですありがとうございます
読み上げなくても結果と思いますけどね
稲垣栄子様と
振動
隆久様それから高畑
良品
さん前田真理子様で4名の方です
ありがとうございます
はい今日のテーマはこの
理性的に生きるためにはどうしたらいい
ですかということで
このリセットという単語をよく仏教で使わ
れるし
林業という言葉ですね
人間の理解能力は様々だから
誰にでも
ブッダの教えが理解できるわけじゃないん
です
ですからこの
深い心理は
ある人々
が聞いてくださいと
全く物事を理解できない人々にとっては
迷惑をかけてはいけないんですねまぁそう
いう人々にはただ道徳的に
どう生きるのかという分かりやすい説法も
結構あります
しかし本当のところは
存在を
解明して
存在を脱出することなんですねそれが大変
なスケールの作業になりますのでこの引用
という言葉よく使われてはいるんです
英訳してみるとインテリジェンスという
言葉になります
はい次に行きます
それでリセットというのはこの
インテリジェンスですね
AIという単語が入っていて
ねあれって何なのかと
喜んでいるんですねAIっていうのはね
人口知能でしたっけね私は
日本語訳は
ねだからほとんど今あの
知らん知らんうちに使ってますね
我々も特にインターネットを使っている
場合は検索する場合は
その検索する人の気持ちに合わせて
いろいろデータ出してくれたりはする
[音楽]
AIっていうのは
この人間がややこしくて考えなくてはいけ
ないことが機械
で考えてもらうとやり取り
組み立ててそれで答えを出してもらおうと
いう
考えですね
しかし人間と他の生命の違うところは
インテリジェンスなんです
理性なんです
ね他の生命にはある程度ではありますけど
身を守るぐらいの
ねそれはあまり開発できないんですね
人間は身を守るという問題はもうさっさと
解決して
それから自分の
理性をインテリジェンス
を他のいろんなことに使っているんですね
それが
俗世間的な人類の発展であり
進化でもあります
これ機械に任せると
人間はもう
恐る
怖いでしょう
退化するん
です動物のレベルに戻ってしまうん
です例えば
昔ね我々と私たちの時代では私たちはこの
外国語を学ぶためには結構苦労するん
です頭の中でももう混乱誰でもいろいろ
違う違う文法でしょうに
いろんなことを覚えなくちゃいけないし
文法と言っても信託ですね
そこを何とかして
暗記しなくちゃいけないし
それでなかなかこの能力を上がるん
でしょう
例えば言語二つ喋れる場合は
物事の見方っていうのは
ね広げちゃうん
です一つの言語しか喋らない人にとっては
もう一つの側面でしか物事見えない
だからもう一つ言語学ぶということは
すごい違う
文化を学んで違う
価値観
違うものの見方
違う思考パターン
学ぶということになります
例えば
似ているやと思うかもしれませんだけど
全然ドイツ語と英語は似ていないんです
英語とフランス語は
似てないん
ですでも同じ
仲間だから勉強できますよ
ドイツ語で喋る時の思考パターンと
フランス語を喋る時に思考パターンが違う
んです
日本車に私に何のことなくできましたけど
ね
全部忘れましたけどね見事に
でこのこれ例に出したのは今AIだからね
要らないね
自分のくだらない言語で喋ってボタンを
押せば向こうはこの必要な言語で
通訳してくれるん
ですだからAI使ったことで
アルゴリズムにねあの自動翻訳
能力入れたところで
我々は言語を学ぶ必要はないんですねだ
から自分知っているところチェックすると
ねまるっきりちんぷんかんぷんですけど
未だにあの親子でも他の言語知らないん
だったらどうしますか
で2週間ぐらい前で私は使っていたあの
血圧計を
スリランカに送ったんです
でもあれ全部日本語だからね
向こうで使えないでしょうそれで
いくらかこの
使い方
向こうに分かるようにしようかなと言っ
たら
持ってる人は自分の携帯で写真
撮って画像で
英語に翻訳してもらったんですねこれいい
んですか
これは英語でも何でもないんだよ
とこれは誰でも分かりませんよ
国の言葉に
集約してもらったっても
この世に存在しない
単語の
並びということになるん
ですそこでもいいでしょうと言って私は
紙に全部日本語英語に書いて
[音楽]
出しましたけど私は書いたフレーズは一つ
も
翻訳機械は出してくれなかったんです
あれは普通使う
英語で
翻訳したんだけど
それで
面白いんですねあれ今みんな使っています
から
何を分かって
理解しているのかとか
だからこの機械
任せ
=人間の能力が
退化するということなんです
これ暗い話ではなくてこれは法則なんです
努力すれば進化するという
トラブルがあってトラブルが能力
乗り越えることで進化するん
ですトラブルがない
困ることはない
努力しなくてもいいだったらその瞬間から
も退化するんでしょう恐ろしいスピードで
仕事がないんですそれ
はそこでこの
何で機械に任せているかというとこの早く
判断して欲しいんですねだから特に
Googleちゃうと
我々に必要なデータ全部出してくれるん
です
時間はかかりません
でも昨日も何か
理論的なところ調べたかったんだけど
私は
Googleと便のAI機能
使わないで
検索したんですがやっぱりそれでももう
わけも分からないものだってくれるんです
ね
こうじゃないでしょうと
また別々方法パターン書いて書いて
必要なところ
一部取ってみたんです
だからこの
今研究する人々にとってはねこのAI
検索っていうのは全部役に立ちますよ
何かのテーマについてどれぐらい論文出て
いるのかとか
ねたらもうあれはもう
ずっと出来てる当然記録されているデータ
だけですけど
出てくる
読まなくても一緒なところだけ
ピンポイントすることもできる
だから私は徹して良かったなと思います
けどなぜならば悪いことやるの能力は結構
あったんです
今のみたいな機械で何でもやってくれるん
だったら
相当することはできるんです
今も時々試しに
AIを私は馬鹿にしてあげたりはします
どんな風に歩けるかというとなんとなく
分かるんだから
それにハメないようにそれも引っ掛かる
ように質問すれば
見事な答えが出てきます
とにかく人間にとってはもう早く
データが出た方がよろしいし早く判断に
できた方がよろしいということがありまし
てそういう風になるんですね
人間がデータ調べて自分で
判断しようとするとすごく時間がかかり
ますね
人間はすごくスローなんです
よだからどんどんどんどん仕事は機械に
奪われてしまうん
です今機会がなければ
我々は何一つもできない状態になっている
んです
それから人間の判断にある
この
どこかでエラーが出ます
これはAIも出しますよエラー
はより気にしない我々は
もっと
検索方法を変えた方がいいやということに
するだけで
だから我々はなんか
信仰しているんですね機会が正しい答え
瞬時に出してくれるんだと
あんなくだらんこと作ったのはくだらん
人間だから
の影響が出てくるんです
そこでこの
理性っていうのは二つですよ一知識
に
判断
この2つを合わせて理性で言うんです
だから理性的に行きたいというテーマでし
たからこのテーマのミネスダールどなたか
提案したテーマで
嫌な顔したっても意味がないんです私が
決めたテーマだったら何で難しいテーマ
決めるのかと私に文句言ったってしょうが
ないんだけど私が決めてないんです
皆様の
いろいろアイディア中から一番簡単な
アイディアを選んだんです
だから内容は難しくなったらその
質問を作った方見つけて
何とかしてください
仏教は理性的に行きなさい
理性が大事です
仏教では仏教を学ぶためには理性が必要や
と
ならなくて言うと
私たちに分かるのは知識と
判断能力なんです
これで問題が出てきますよ
即世間で知識って何ですか
ねこれにリミットがないでしょう
どこまで知識を得れば人間として十分
でしょうか
わからんです
ねそれから知識っていうのはずっとバイ
ビーラスみたいに増えるんです
だから勉強してもしても
勉強して終わった途端その世界に対しても
新たなアイデアがまた出ている
これやりきれないん
です
思い出した例えばね雨漏りする家の中に
いるような感じでもうずっと雨が降って
いる自分がタオルを持ってもう全部あれ水
を取って
絞って
捨てるまた絞って捨てるどこまで減るん
ですか
家の中に
水が漏れてくるん
ですだから家と自分であるならば
もういても立ってもいられない状態になり
ますよ知識得ても
またまたまたまた知識が
増えていくんでしょう
にそこで
増えるだけじゃない知識って消えることも
あります
前の知識はあれはもう今だめです間違って
いる関係ない
ということになるでしょう
昔はお医者さんが患者さんを見たでしょう
今のおじさんは患者さんを見ない
パソコンモニター画面見ている
で判断全部してもう
治療こういうこういうことをしてください
と思っているんです
だから昔そうじゃなくてアナログ的に
身体いろいろ調べてみて
質問も聞いていろんなことやってちょっと
時間もかかりましたし
[音楽]
今流れの中まで全部見えますよということ
で私はそれも見えてないだろうという感じ
なんですけどね
相当
推測しなくちゃあかんでしょうとね今
いろんな機械で出してくる画像やらデータ
をねそれはそんなに当てにならんだろうと
[音楽]
だから
知識ねすごい大事にして知識は今
もう使えない
間違っていることになる
時々間違ったという
証拠じゃないんだけど
みんな興味ない
古い知識の中でも
人間
びっくりするほどの知識もあります
よ興味ない
ということになる
それから知識ある人が事実知ってますか
ね知識に
罠それなんです
データによって変わるもので知識とは真理
ではありません
だから
膨大な知識自分の脳みそに溜まったからと
言って
あまり意味がないあれって真理ではないん
だから
例えば日本のあの孤児という本があります
読んだことないんだけど
英訳もあるのに
これ誰かに暗記することできるでしょう
古い日本語だから
結構調子に乗って暗記することはできます
全部暗記したらその人にはそれにの知識
あるでしょう
だからこの人実知ってる人間ですか
ね書いているものはどこまで事実でどこ
まで作品か分かる分からないでしょう
だから
我々すごい知識欲ありますよ
知識があっても
なんか
当てにならんね
それから
脳みその中で入れられる知識量っていうの
はそんなたくさんないん
ですだから我々生きている世界は我々は
いろんな
分野に分けているん
ですだから一人の人間がほんのわずかな
分野を
研究して知識に
するもう一人は別なこともう一人は別な
ことそうやって知識はこの専門分野に
分けて分けて分けて分けてきめ細かく分け
ているんですよ
だから知識人っていうのは一部知っている
人って意味なんです
知識人というのは物事を知っている人では
ないん
一部知っている
今誰だって経験しているでしょう
にそれで知識は変わりますからねそこで
知識という英語ではのち真理って
いうのは変わらないんで真理は
これはもう事実
知識の中にも事実一応ありますよ地球は
自転しているんだというような感じ
そこでその知識が
なかった時も地球は自転していたんですね
地球は自転しているんだと
分かっても地球は自転している
地球の自転にとっては人間それ知っている
か知ってないかと関係ないん
だからそれが
それが変わらないん
ですだから知識を通してこの調子に行く
ならばいくらか安心なんです
でもそれってできるのかと
例えば物理学割れますね
物質を調べてい
てどんどん
潰すということに近寄っていくんだ
と最終的にはアインシュタインさんの悪い
のなんたらかんだられるのですごいこと
本当にそうですかねと
事実に達したのか
とでコンデンスが出てきたらあれ全部壊れ
てしまったん
ですそれから
病気に対する
治療があったらね
真理に達したらこれで問題終わりOK
でしょう
なってないん
です人は病気になるということは事実です
だったらそれに対応する
治療法を見つけてよと
証拠で
[音楽]
何か変になっちゃうんですね
1年2年で
治療法が変わっちゃうん
それでまた
治療法改良するん
ですということは
病気に対する
治療ということを発見してないということ
なんです
これで自分の国では西洋
医学と
スリランカの伝統医学はかなりお互いに
基盤向いているんです
なぜか西洋的に
病気体というものは何でもかんでも伝統
医学でも
治療できるんです
で
切ったり貼ったりすることが
伝統医学では
禁止なんです
これは身体に治すことではなくてさらに
悪化させることや
と人が木から落ちて怪我したらそれは直し
てあげます
自分でわざわざと切ることはしません
そこで何で牙向いているのかと言うと
伝統医学にあなた方の治療っていうのは
全然変わってないでしょう
に
遠い昔イスカも分かってない昔から決めた
リストでその
薬でその調合で
ずーっと上げているだけでしょうに
だから
リスト学んだら医者っていうのはねなんか
変だよと
それはこちら別に変わる必要ないんだよ
理由は
治るん
です今の問題はその
薬がないん
自然破壊で
だからこの子の病気にこの子の植物だよ
決まっているんです
でも西洋ではそう決まってないんです
新しく
研究して新しい
薬開発する
まぁそれは冗談で例え話で言ったんだけど
[音楽]
やっぱりある病にこの
薬屋とはっきり決めたならば
帰る必要ないん
ですから
病気に対する
治療というケースの場合でも
未だに真理に達してないん
です
いろいろ理由ありますよ
1名病気になるのかということは未だに
研究中なんです
それはまだ知り過ごしてないん
ですそれでこれでこうなるこれでこうなる
これでこうなると
言っても
また別な
原因も見つかったりはする
例えばなぜ
癌にかかるのかと誰も分からないでしょう
未だ
にだったらがん治療は成り立たないん
ですネットで見たらもう全く手に負えない
癌も
伝統的な医者が治したというデータ
いろいろ出回ったりするんだけど行って
調べることはできませんからまぁやって
くださいするんだけどねその場合は
なぜ癌になるのかということは知ってます
だから
身体壊してはならん身体はずっと壊してき
たんだから癌になっているん
ですだから
身体をものすごくこのリフレッシュして
あげるんです細胞たち
いろんな
毒
溜まってる毒を
落として
リフレッシュさせるん
ですそうすると何のことなく見事にあれも
消えているんですそれはちゃんと西洋の
検査してもらってちゃんと治りましたと
いう保証は取っちゃいますけどね
だから
原因知ったら
答えが見つかります
ねはいそれ言ったのはどれほど知識が広い
かというと医学世界
未だにそういう全く
把握できないそれで一人個人が
医学世界に挑戦すると言ってもこれ
成り立たない
だから本能はつかない一部だけ選んで
研究しなくちゃいけないん
でそういうことで
理性します自然な人間になろうと思ったら
第一のハードルは知識なんです
知識で満たした人間にはなれません
で
さらさらと私は関節に言ったのは知識で
大したことはないんだよでも
全く関係ないいらないと意味じゃないん
ですまぁ
一緒ですけど
ね変わるもの
はい次行ってみます
変化する知識全ての知識を得ることは不
可能ですね当たり前ですね人の知識には
制限がありますねそれも当たり前
それも新たな知識によって変わるからそれ
ほど頼りにならない
我々知識人になってもそれその知識は
頼りにならない
すごい年取った
有名な教授たちとかいるでしょう
病気で倒れてベッドにいる
あの偉大なる知識はもう関係なくなっ
ちゃうね
個人にあるのはこれ
理解しましょう一人一人個人に
リミテッド
ある一部の知識は得られます
それ以上頑張らなくても例えばフランス語
喋るようにしたいなあと思って
頑張ってみたらうまくいかないんだったら
別に
まぁ二十歳まではいくらでも言語入れる
能力あります
その時はその
脳のそのセクションが結構
元気で頑張るんですだいたいどんな人間の
中で我々使っている言語を
改良するの若者でしょう
新しいフレーズ作って作って作って
言語に入れちゃってそれが普通になっ
ちゃって次の世界はまたあれも変えて
新しい
プレイしたら使い方
だから言語は生きているものになっている
のは若者のせいなんです
年取っちゃうとセットプレイして喋るだけ
で何の面白くもないん
です若者を喋ると年寄りだったらそれから
あなた行ったこと通訳してくださいと言わ
ないと何言ってるかわからないぐらい
新しいフレーズばっかり言っているんです
から
年齢の問題もありますよだからただ冷凍し
て言語を出しただけで
二十歳まで
まあもうちょっと伸ばしてもいいんだけど
いろんな新しい言語
は学びたければ学べる
年取っていくと
頑張ってもなんかどこかでブレーキかかっ
ちゃうんですね
そういうわけで
例えば数学の教授たち天才たち
も35歳までですね
あの能力は
それから普通の発作になっちゃうんです
小学ではもう世界的にしっかり驚かせ
ちゃってびっくりさせているとか
ね若い時だけです
はいそういうことで我々は
何か正しい判断しようと思っちゃうとこの
知識の
制限あること
が問題になるんですだから我々は何か判断
しても何か決めても私たちは全てのデータ
調べたわけじゃないんです
それよく見えるのは何が世界で社会で問題
起きちゃうと
解決方法
いろんな人はいろんなことを
ハチャメチャなんです
いつでもそうでしょう
具体的で考えた方がやりやすいんだけど
例えば
子供達の
教育現場より明るくて
もうどんどん
能力が上がるような
すごくなんて言いますかこの
教育は苦にならない
楽しい
教育システムあった方がいいと
それで
では次にどうすればそうなると聞いてみて
くださいそれ
判断でしょう
そうするとそれぞれ人は自分勝手な判断
するでしょう
100人に生きれば100通りの答えが出
てくる
それで実行不可能ということになっちゃう
んですどんな問題にも同じことでねどう
すれば世界は平和になるのかいと聞い
ちゃうと一人一人が
自分の判断言うん
ですですから
一つの問題になぜたくさん
答えがあるんですか
ね一つの問題に対してどれぐらい
答えがあるのかとてもわからないんです
その
答え見てもなんか実行不可能
今の例で言えばねクライムとロシア人
コロシアムやるんじゃなくて
二人がどこかでご飯食べて
ウォッカ飲みながら
問題話し合った方がいいでしょう
仲良しで友達で
友達っていうのはまぁわがままでも
成り立たないんだから
ねだからまぁロシアもいくらか控えなく
ちゃいけないところがあるしいくらも控え
なくちゃいけないところがあってそこは
話し合って合意していやこれから二人とも
友達やとかね
終わりでしょう戦争は
俺一つの答えでしょう
で一番これでハンディは自己不可能ですね
あの二人も頭いかれているんだからね
精霊好きと
プチンが
頭いかれた二人
テーブルで座って
ウォッカ飲みながら
喋ると
成り立たないん
俺こそ偉いと思っているんだから
お前はどうかさしなさいよ
だから
そういう風に具体的に何か問題があったら
どうすればいいかと言えば今私は一つの
答えだったでしょう
もう一つ
答えとかね中国やらアメリカやらもう
インドネシアナルフォーラムで話し合った
方がいいんじゃないかとかね国連で何か
決めた方がいろんなこと言え
ます何言ったってもあいつら殺せやるん
ですハチャメチャになるまで
それで何で一つの問題に例えば
喉が渇いた
じゃ水飲みなさい
でしょOK
じゃないよ
喉が
渇いたからと言って水飲めばいいわけじゃ
ない場合もありますよ世の中で
これは稀なケースかもしれませんだけど
まぁ誰も
喉が渇いたことで人生問題引き起こした
ことないんだからね簡単ね
終わり話は
そういう風にシンプルにならないね人生は
ずっと困るん
です旦那さんの帰りは遅い
気になる問題でしょう
それで奥さんとして早く
解決策を
探すでしょうないん
ですそのまま悩んでください死ぬまで
ないんです
で旦那の立場から自分の
家内はちょっと
屏風
だから
私のでそれでいてくださいよ
解決策出しても
早く300500
種類
一番種類でも
解決策言えるでしょう
もしかすると奥様が
精神的に何か不満持っているかもその不安
なんか探してそれ何とかすればいいんじゃ
ないかとかね
あれはこれとか
ねあるいは
まあやっぱり今の世界ではね
収入でやり取りはちょっとかなり厳しい
そこで意識してしまっちゃって
凶暴になっているとか
答えは出すは出すは一つもあんまりうまく
いかないよこの世の中でだから
理性的には人がガチャガチャガチャガチャ
どうすればどうすればいいかというと私の
答えたって判断しない
私で
もということは言わないんであまり
わからないでくださいあれは
物理的に死んでくださいという意味じゃ
ないんですあの文学的に
そこに私の答え全部入っているんです本当
は
要するにどうすればいいと聞いても
それには
答え何通りもあるしこれ数えられないん
ですね
それぞれ実行してみてもうまくいかないと
いう音もあるんです
ですから死ねって答えです自分が死んだ
ものやと思って何も死んだ人に何も関係
ないでしょう
そういう風に生きていれば
この料理作ったけどこれすごく美味しい
でしょう私は死んでいるんだから分からん
よ
とだって食べてみたら本当にまずいんだ
けどこれ言えないでしょう
だったら聞く必要もないでしょう
それで苦労してまぁなかなかいいですねと
か
ね
こんな生き方です死んだ方が楽ですよ
今日は食料
値段がすごくあったかくて
もうあれこれとこれとこれと買うことは
できませんですかね
もうちょっと私死んでいるんだからねそれ
でいいんじゃない
焼肉作りたかったんだけど
肉買うお金はないかったと
死んでいるんだから焼肉でもただの豆腐で
も別に取ったことはないや
だから
いろんな問題にいいからって
余計な戦争を引き起こす総理は死んで生き
た方がいいん
です
はいまぁこれ死んでいってそれはあまり
このあまり使えない単語かもしれませんだ
けど
ここでポイントは
我々は
理性でしっかり判断して生きてみようと
思っても
判断あるいは問題に
解決策っていうのは
あるある
解決策はいくらでもあります
しかし一つをうまくいかない
=
解決策はありませんでしょう
人が作る問題
はい次行ってみます
はいそれでセカンドセクション知識は
そんなもんで
適当な知識人になってください
何でもSiriでなくてもいいんです
一個二つぐらい知っているそれで十分です
役に立ちます
生きるためにはこの
判断が必要です
生きるとはこの真空への行為なんです
大したことはないんで
身体が行為している
喋っている考えている
生きているん
ですで
我々は意図的に体を使っている場合あるん
だけど無意識的にも身体が行為しているん
です心臓は鼓動するは欠席は流れるわ
酸素が入る前に酸化炭素は出す
は血液から
汚れたものはねこうして
いくらいろんなことやってます
ものすごく行為はやっていますそれはまぁ
心で管理しないんだからオートで起きます
しかし試み乱れるとこの応答のセクション
の乱れてしまいます
だから心臓はどうやったって駆動してくる
だろうと調子に乗っちゃうと
そこでトラブルが起こすん
ですだから自分の肉体に対しても時間が
あった方がいいん
です実感があって落ち着いているとこの
身体の細胞たちが細胞システムたちが問題
なく
動くんです
それから我々歩いたり座ったり物を取っ
たり物を書いたり料理作ったりとか身体
使ってます
ねそれには
判断するということが必要です
喋る場合も
判断して喋らなくちゃいけない
で考える場合でも
判断するために考える場合もあるし
判断そのものを思考そのものも判断に
なるんですね
例えば
今日はちょっと
暑いと考える
もう判断しているでしょう
だから思考がそのまま
判断でもあります
ですからこれみんなにこのやめなさいと
言っても止めてくれないのそういうわけな
んです
それで病気になって人生ダメになりますよ
とよく分かりましたと言ってそのパターン
でまた考えるん
ですやめてくれない
だから自分の
妄想が
判断なんです
生きるとは判断して真空のために
行為をし続けることになります
判断は正しければ人生に問題はありません
コーヒーにね砂糖を入れようと思って寝て
いますから
塩を入れる
これは正しい判断じゃないん
ですであんな正しければ
全然大丈夫ですね
問題は
判断するために知識というデータを
参考にしなくちゃあかんでしょう
これハチャメチャですね
当てにならない知識は自分にあるのは
わずかな知識だけ
例えば家にいるピアニストの人は
焼肉食べたくなる
でも一日中ピアノを叩いているだけで
正直かける能力もないん
です当然料理できないでしょう
その知識ないん
だから
弱肉作ろうと言うといろんなことをどんな
材料必要でしょうかとかどんな
量でしょうかとかねどんな順番で作るのか
とか
ねでタレっていう独立するでしょうじゃあ
どんな毒を入れるのかとか
ねだから何から何まで
判断して行うだから料理できる人にはその
知識がありますね
だからその人に頼むんですねこういう料理
作ってください
だから
我々は時々自分に知識ないのにやろうと
するでしょう
決まって
答え最悪でしょうに
何で人間自分に能力ないものもやりたがる
んですか
ねそれは理性とは言えない
ねだから自分のちっちゃな知識セット見て
ここ
ら辺でこういう仕事ならできると
でもこういうこういうことはできないと
で何ができて何ができないのかぐらい知っ
た方がいいんですそれでできた人が
判断してもその人は全てのデータ参考した
わけじゃないんです
自分の知識データはほとんど
僅かです
ですからどんな
判断しても
間違いだらけなんです
からこの最後のフレーズ覚えておき
ましょう
人生は間違いの連作です
普通ですそれ
は驚く必要ない驚くならば超馬鹿者です
仏壇には入れないもう失格
人生って何
て間違いの連続
です
失敗の連続です
これ
喋ってる私も同じです
時々加工考えちゃいますよ
間違い間違いやらなかってよかったやら
なかってくれる
ことばかりなんです
あれやって良かったのなかなか思い出せ
ないん
ですこの間あれやってよかった時とかやっ
て楽しかったということあるんです
結構楽しかったでも
やらなかった方が良かったっていうことも
出てくる
そういうわけで
理性の人間になりたければこのフレーズを
覚えておきましょう
人生とは
間違いの連続でしたということ
です必要な知識が全てあると
仮定しましょうありえないんです
現実的にはありえないことそれでも
判断を行うと冷えマンエラーが現れます
全て知っている人がいるとしましょう
いるわけないんだけど
その人は
判断する
それでもヒューマンエラーが出ます例えば
この普通の仕事世界で
ものすごいそれ気をつけるんです
例えば飛行機の操縦する
技術者さんたちが
ね勉強していますよ
訓練も受けてます
他勉強してないんですそれしか知らないん
ですだってお店は小さいんだからね
それでも信頼できないんですよ
少女をしていると
何かしら冷えもニラが出る可能性あります
飛行機の場合はヒューマンニラはとっても
ありがたいこと感なの阿弥陀様にとっては
我々にとっては最悪ですね
阿弥陀様は良かったみんな私のところに
来るんだと喜ぶかもしれませんだけど
みんな死んじゃいますからねだから飛行機
の場合はほとんど
弟とAIでAIで
データやあれやこれやとほとんど自動的に
入って
動くんです
だから着陸するまでオートパイ入れてでき
ます
なぜかと言うと
ヒューマンエラーが出ます
で私は
病院に行く時は他行くところないんです私
に
何か楽しみに行きたいと言ったら病院だけ
ですから
検査する時はガラスとそちらの名前とか
貼ってますけどね
向こうの韓国さんがじゃあ名前言って
くださいと
自分の名前貼っているんだから聞かなくて
もいいでしょうでもエラーが出る可能性
ありますよ
だから何回も
身体にすごい
危険なものを調査したりする場合あります
ね検査の時は
ね注射する前に
名前てくださいとか
生年月日言ってくださいと
私も横になってうるさいなこの連中はもう
ずっと
契約して全部準備しているのにもやれば
いいのにとかうるさいと思いつつも全部
答えるんですなぜかというと
どこかで平凡ならが
起こる可能性があります
今回決して喧嘩で私はもう名前入ったって
本人によくわからんだから私は
ワイルドとって
これ私の名前です
ちょっと大きいですはいOKです
そういうわけで世の中で専門家の世界でで
も
専門家っていうのはちっちゃいんです
派閥小さいんです
狭いんですね
これ仕方がないんです
幅が狭いんだけど
結婚している
外科は自分の世界で自分の専門セクション
だけ
生きるんだけど
終わった途端何かにバトンタッチ
それでも
判断ミス起こる可能性あります
はいこれ
理解しましょうだから
嘘で
仮定しても全て知っている人がいるんだよ
と
が出る可能性あり
ますじゃあ思い出したんですお釈迦様の
あるエピソード
ですごい地方にいてハリウッド
が
3ヶ月間かもう長いでそこでたくさんの
若い人々は仏教に興味を抱いて
いるのは知恵の第一で
教えることは
抜群能力があるん
ですそこで誰だって若い人々は
何かいるところにいたいんですただ
ものすごい知恵が自分に入るんだから
ねで結構若い人々が来て
修行したいんだと出家しちゃったん
です
教えてあげてまぁそろそろ私の出かける
時期になりましたから
君たちも私と一緒に
ブッダに会ってみたらどうですか
goodにやってないんです
これはありがたい
存在の師匠でしょ
歩いて歩いて歩いて歩いて何日もかけて
歩いて出たん
ですで最上の
時はかなり
遅くなってます暗くなってます
だから
ブッダに合う
ブッダに意識になりますから
ねその時ブッダに会えないんです誰も
それでみんなじゃあもう今日いろいろ夜
過ごす場所を決めて
お釈迦様皆に
面会するときは会いましょうということで
だからこの若い連中はじゃあ私はこちら
あなたはこちらは私はこちらでのこちら
欲しいとかねいやこちら私だけに取ったん
だからなんかちょっとちょっと大騒ぎに
なったんです大騒ぎでもないんだけど
ちょっとしゃべることになったんです
ぶっちゃけいるところで喋ることはないん
です誰も
だから夜止まる場所を認める場合も
責任者がいるん
です山河の中で
その人に
30年いますけどと言った方で十分です
その人は30人行って一人こちら指で見せ
てあげるだけ
喋る必要ないん
ですこの人々若い連中が
どうせあの学校のあれみたいな感じで夜
うるさいんですよ
止まる時は
昼は大人しくいるんだけど
ねお釈迦様は
何でこの
魚と撮ってるところみたいな感じで大騒ぎ
ですかとあれすごい非難の単語なんです
魚取っている
網で
大騒ぎでその時
すぐ売れなくちゃいかんでしょだから
キャーキャーキャーと喋りながら売るん
です
がお釈迦様のすごい地方から
触り心地の弟子たちグループが来ているん
だよ
うるさい
出て行きなさい
命じます
とそういう風に言ったんです
胎教に入ります
行ったら何でそんだけの仕事だから
レポートに頭下げて
ブッダにこういう風な言葉言われましたよ
と言ったらされるものじゃ何のこともなく
はい自分の子供と価値ところも取りなさい
出て行きましょう
お釈迦様に追い出されましたよと
出て行くん
です出来るとこの町の
議会が集まっているんです
たくさんの坊さん達が来たんだからみんな
もうちょっと食事とかねちょっと余分作っ
た方がいいんじゃない明日とかねいろいろ
話しているところで
来た人々はまた出て行くんです
か
そうですけどお釈迦様に
追い出されましたよ
と言ったらこの最強の方々ちょっと待って
くださいと
言ってそこで待ってもらってお釈迦様の
ところに行って
最近の人々のお釈迦様あれって何ですかね
とか
あれで若い人々でしょうに
仏道をやりたいとすごい真剣に頑張って
いる人々でしょう
にそんなに
退去命令し納得いっちゃうとみんなも何て
言いますか
修行する気持ちもなくなっちゃって
減速するかもしれません
と若い連中だからどうやってもお釈迦様
あそうかじゃあ却下します
退去命令
ね取り上げます
言ったらありがとうございます
お釈迦様の
退去を取り上げましたのでどうぞ戻って
くださいとでまた戻るんです
あのお釈迦様でしょう
一つ判断しました
すぐその判断変えました
判断そんな
ただの最期の人が言ったからと言って帰る
わけないでしょう
でまぁそれは別にお釈迦様の判断ミスとし
て使ってますけどそれは本当は判断ミス
じゃないんです
若者たちをちょっと
脅したかっただけな
んで遊びじゃないやってこの世界が
すごい真剣に
修行しなくちゃいかんということでねまぁ
それからお釈迦様何もなかったような感じ
でみんな読んでもらって
説法して
みんなあらかんに悟りましたけどねだから
なんか面白いでしょう
お釈迦様でも
判断したんだけどすぐそれ変えることに
なりました
それは決してあのヒューマンエラーでも
ないんだけどとにかく
我々は
ブッダみたいに必要な知識全部終わって
判断しても
人間だからもしかするお釈迦様人間だから
うるさい思った可能性もありますね
うるさいこの連中は
追い出しなさい
このガキたちが
我々もスリランカでは結構ガキたち
追い出したりする場合ありますよ
寺は大判だから勝手に来て
ハチャメチャありゃこれやっているともう
我慢できない状態になってくるんですね他
の法要ができなくなって
追い出します
追い出しちゃうと子供達もよく分かるんだ
から
出て行って
法要が
終わるかなと思ってくるとまた上げてまた
大騒ぎし始めるんですその時は代表です
から
それって昔話で
ですから一人一人が
判断する
判断することは
結局は自分の主観になるん
です客観的な判断でも主観で行うん
です2+2=4でしょう
でもそれは最初に学んだ時は
自分の主観的な判断なん
です今も誰かが私は2+2=と言ったら私
4と答えなくちゃあかんでしょう
4と答えませんだけど
期待しないでくださいその人に合わせて
答え出しますけど
消化できるならば
[音楽]
でも2+2はできたら
読んだと答える場合でもあれ客観的な
判断じゃない
よ自分の判断でもあります
だから
判断とは
客観的にやってくださいというの決まり
客観的な判断しても
あれ主観的な判断でもあります
人間はAIではないん
ですアルゴリズムで生きているわけじゃ
ないんです
はいその
微妙なところで
ブッダ入ります
大抵わかるでしょう仏教はこんなどんな
もんかと
どんな軽々しく
皆のものはそれ聞いてみなさい
程度じゃないんです
理性について語る場合はお釈迦様がこの
ヒューマンネラ主観で
判断するんだからそこら辺ちょっと手入れ
て直すん
ですだから全て知識なくてもOKです
知っている知識で判断するんですその
判断が間違うかもしれません
仕方がないでしょう
しかし
とんでもない間違いだけはごめんでしょう
飛行機の
操縦するも
ちょびちょびっと間違いを起こすかも
それは別にどういうことはないん
では参考する何とか本みたいなものあるん
だからそこはこちらにかけておくという
ことは
オートでやるんだけどあれ取ってみてこう
いう風に
右側に置いた可能性もありますそれはミス
です
ちゃんとある決まっている場所に置かなく
ちゃいかんまあそれぐらいは大きい問題
じゃないん
です着陸する時はランニング
ギアのあれ上げなかったら結構大変ですね
みんな死にます
でもそれは今応答で
あれがダラダラと入ってきます
でもはい
人間にできることは
犯すことではなく
少なくすることです
間違い少なくする
少ない間違いも
その別にという感じでの間違いだったら
危険はないんですね
はい
GOODSの方に行きます
判断する時のバイアスがあるんです
バイアスは感情です
1番目のバイアスは好みなんです
パーリ語でちゃんと言うん
です数学の問題のように
純客観的な判断は生きる世界ではありえ
ません
大体アバウトで例えば料理に教え
どれぐらいありません
少々です
ね4ミリグラム入れてくださいと誰も言い
ません
40mg入れて言わない
ねはい
塩少々
それが人生なんです
だから料理する人々は
塩少々かけます
あの
塩少々は
曖昧でも
いい加減で別に大したことないよ
それで死んだ人はいないしね
受け取らない
もうちょっと
刺激がという感じで
ね終わります
ですから正しくない判断になるバイアスが
4つあります一番目はちゃんと
好みということなんです
例えば
塩は少々入れると
塩好きな人がいるん
です特に日本の方々日本料理は
塩は決めてだと言っているでしょう
私は塩好きじゃないんですだからすごい
使用は決めているこうなっちゃうんです
でも別に塩辛いってわけじゃないんだけど
やっぱり必要はちょっと
入ってますね
私たちはこの代わりで勝負するん
ですなんかいい香りが出たらOKとの料理
が自分の香り持ってますけど
どうでもいいんだよそんなのとにかく
塩少々と言ってもその個人の
好み
入るかも
だから私が料理作る場合は
もし私が食べるならば
足を入れたよと言うための言い訳のために
入れるだけで
今日私は食べませんこのが食べますと思っ
ちゃうと何の遠慮もなく言われちゃうん
ですだからそんなもんでだから言いたかっ
たのは個人の
好みが入るということなんです
判断に
個人の好みに入ってはいけません
赤ちゃんに離乳食あげる場合はお母さんの
好みでの味で食べさせていいわけじゃない
でしょう
このちゃんだっていうのは欲の
狩場線です
欲の感情のスペクトラムがあります
欲ってかなり
幅広い
欲の種類があるんです
まぁアバウトで数字で言えば500種類
ぐらいあります
だいたい500種類に無理やり数えている
んです
覚えてもらうためにスペクトラムがあり
ますよ
とだったら下落にしたならば
1500になるん
ですだから我々は欲と言ったら何を思うん
ですか
ねいろんなインスペクトいろんなものあり
ます
貪欲というね強烈でどうしようもないば
病気になっている
場合もあってあれって好きだなという軽い
欲もあって
この間のどんな
欲が
絡んでも
判断にはバイアスです
だから気をつけましょうと判断する時は
自分
好みというものは
使わない
そこで客観的になる
料理作る場合は自分
好みでもなくこの人々の好みでもなくこの
料理はこのように作るものであると
この目でなくでもこの料理の場合はまず油
で傷めなくちゃいけないと
この料理には自分があまり好きじゃないん
だけど
バター入れなくちゃいけないんだと
いう風にあるでしょう
判断は好みに合わせると正しくない
開く結果になります
欲の摂取によって
判断ミスの代償が現れます
これ毎日やることですよそれも
好みで
判断するそれやめてくださいということね
やめることはできませんだけどどんどん
どんどん勉強して勉強して勉強して
能力上げた方がいいんですはい次に来ます
バイアスに
判断するから
怒りなんですね怒りと言ったっても
軽いバージョンだから私は不機嫌という
単語入れたんです
別に
激怒しているわけじゃないでちょっと不
機嫌
不機嫌だった途端判断はそこで間違えます
けど怒りですねこちらにも広い
スペクトラムがあります
不機嫌の気持ちは自分に他人に
判断に必要なデータ
出来事などに当てはめますだから不機嫌と
言ったっても何でやと
例えばこれこれ何とかやってくださいと
頼む
頼めるとそれがやりたくない
だから
頼まれた仕事に対して不機嫌になっちゃっ
た仕事したくないではないん
あれは自分の体調が
良くないとか
疲れているとか
ねちょっとお茶のお茶のお茶飲みか飲み
たかったとか
ねその時あのねこうじゃなくてこれって
言っちゃうとちょっとになっちゃう
ねだからいろんな不機嫌いろんな怒りが
あるん
です結構ベトナムがあるん
ですそこはこの大きくなってくると戦争
人殺しになるん
ですあれも不機嫌で判断するん
です不機嫌なところじゃないその場合は
激怒
で判断するだからその判断は間違い
爆弾を落としてやるぞと
判断は
完璧間違い大変危険
何でそんな判断したのかとだってそれで
自然破壊して人間がせっかく苦労して作っ
た建物ハシビル工場
灰にして言い訳ないでしょう
でも気にしない
判断したんだから
ですからこの不機嫌でやる判断もかなり
危険ですでもどの程度で不機嫌がっという
ことによって
結果が変わります
危険度が変わります
もう一つ問題はこの
怒りのバイアス入ると
[音楽]
参考するべきデータ
参考しないということになる
でこれ具体的な例は難しいんだけど自分の
国のことをよくよく心配ですからね国の
裁判のやってる連中が
政府の機嫌取るために判決出すん
ですだから
警察の側が出した証拠だけ見てじゃあ
決めちゃうん
です相手の言い分は聞かない
だからデータ一部だけ一部だけ見て他
捨てちゃうとか
裁判の場合は
警察側がこういうこういうこういう問題は
起こしましたとこれこれぐらい証拠や
それぞれ
弁護する側も
これこれはこれでこういうことはこういう
ことでこういうことでこういうことと言わ
なくちゃいけない
両方考えてから
どちらの方でしょうか
ともう完璧やっぱり有罪だったら有罪に
するまぁあちらの言うところにも目がある
しこちらに問題があるしだったらまぁある
程度でじゃあこんなことにしましょうと
いう判断しなくちゃあかんだけど
そこで被告人のこと気に入らなかったとか
マスコミで結構批判されているからとか
やっぱりこいつは悪人だが気持ち悪いやつ
やと思っちゃうとあの裁判官の
判決は間違いなんです
そういうわけで
政治家が判断する時でも
奥さんが判断する時でも学校の教師が判断
するときでも不機嫌の気持ち入るとこの
判断は
良くない
だから不機嫌の
程度スペクトラムの程度によって
危険とか
ねになります
時々不機嫌で怒りで判断することで
だいたい
犯す場合もあります
はい次に行きます
でバイアスの3
恐怖
これってどんな生命にはありますね恐怖は
生きることに
繋がってますよ恐怖は
夫婦を感じない人間がいないんですしかし
お釈迦様言うのは人生の
判断する時は
恐怖を使わないでください
これすごく難しいんです
例えばスナイパーが外から待っていてある
人にお前この店に入ってこの
店のダイヤを盗んで
外へ出して出してなさいと
こちら車が止まっているかはその車に入れ
てくださいと
一般の人だからあれ店の
店員さんだからやりたくないでしょうでも
スナイパー遠くから
狙っている
とやっちゃいね
それは恐怖感でしょ
スナイパーの
レーザー光線当たっている
そうするとしょうがないんでしょう店の
天元であっても
ガラスを破って
大丈夫
盗ん
で持ってあの
決めた車に入れちゃう
その人は逮捕されて
裁判かけられますけど
こういう出来事をあったと言ったって
見つからなかったらしょうがないでしょう
スナイパー至ってあなたに言い訳だと言っ
ちゃったら終わりでしょう
だから
恐怖感でのどんな人間にも動物にもある
それでもってそれを
判断に使ってはいけない
世界の大好き恐怖感がある将来に対する
恐怖を考える
人のことを怖いと思う場合もあるし
政治に対して
政治が怖いとかね
経済
科か経済状況から
恐怖感が出てくる
時々
非難されたらやばいと思ったりもする
他人に批判されることで恐怖を覚える
自分に自信がない時もこれは恐怖で
こういう風になります
いろんなことで恐怖を感じるんです
それで恐怖の場合は強弱があります
いわゆるスペクトラムがあります
常に我々には恐怖ありますよ
それは死に対する
病気に対する
恐怖な病気にかかりたくないという
死にたくないあまりもずっとあるんだから
それほど感じない
それはベースでそれをいろんな恐怖感が
あります
だから
恐怖で判断すると間違った判断になります
はい早く行きます吸いましょうバイアス4
これは地いわゆる無知の無知です
ね
そこで我々はどんな
判断しても
無知が背景にいるん
です仕方がない
だって人は全て知っているわけじゃない
でしょう
学校の教習は授業やってますけどその全て
知っているわけじゃないん
ですでしかし
授業やってる時は別に無知が
血が入っているわけじゃないんだけど
やっぱり手術する先生も手術する時は結構
緊張します
いくら腕が
あっても
経験があっても緊張はするん
ですケースバイ系で緊張する
しかし指示する医者はちゃんと自分の知識
で
経験を生かしてやりますよだからOKなん
ですけど
でも命っていうのはよく分からんもんだ
からうまくいくか行かないかよくわからん
だから
ちょっと
わからんというところもありますね
しかしこの無知が思ったり出てくると
最悪
怒りよりも欲よりも
恐怖よりも最悪
無知が割り込むと我々は判断しますよ
軽く判断すれ
緊張もしない
偉そうにこうしましょう
こうに決まっていると
この無茶な人はデータ
参考にしない
全くも
どうでもいいやそんなのか
あれはもう分からなくこの問題どうしよう
かとわかるんだからまあとにかく押し
ましょうと
わからんだけどとにかく申しますという
場合は無知なんだなん
です
根拠のない判断になりますね
だから
判断をする時は
根拠のない判断しないように気をつけなく
ちゃいけない
世の中でそういう判断無数にあるん
でしょう
ニュースで流されているニュースと思って
いるのはほとんど
根拠のない判断でできたことがニュースに
しているん
です
自分のたちの人生ではねこのすっごく
困っているのは人の判断なんですその判断
無知で判断しているん
です
みんな困らなくちゃあかんです
例えば世界の経済状況不安
で無知な連中ばかりかけてあれやこれいい
加減なことやってるんだから
そうなるんです
たくさん具体的なデータ頭にあったんだ
けど忘れましただからもう時間もないんだ
から次に行きます
間違い少なく
私たちの
提案は間違い少なく間違いゼロではないん
です
無限の情報の中で
完全完璧
判断は
成り立たないんですしかし
判断を行う自分の心を
管理することはできます
だって心を管理することはできます
判断を間違える4つのバイアスを
理解しましょう
理解してバイアスだけは入らないように気
をつける
ちゃんと好みどうせ怒りバリア恐怖は
幅広いスペクトラムが持っています
無知に対して私はペトロのことは言わ
なかったんです
スペクションも成り立たない
ただなんか
煙みたいな
闇なんですね
闇のスペクトラムはないでしょう
で実況する実行すると
理性的に生きる人間になります
理性的ってのはそんなもんなんでしょう
俗世間でね会社に行って仕事教えて家に
帰って
買い物に行って買い物して家に帰って掃除
をして料理を作って普通に生きるでしょう
その時はずーっと心のリスペンして
この4つのバイアスは使わないことにする
これに自分の心を理解することの支えに
なる
知識を
習得することも悪くないそこで
お釈迦様次に知識習得しなさいと言うん
ですまぁ言ってはないんだけど
順番そうなるんです何のために知識かと
いうと
4つのバイアス入らないように気をつける
ために
必要な知識はあった方がいいん
ですはい次に行きます
実家になっちゃったね
これシャッターとはすごい長いんだけど
ですからこの次に
理性で生きるためにもいくつか知識が必要
です
だから
医学数学じゃないん
ですちゃんと
知っておくため
に知識なん
ですこれはクルーシャンの歴史というん
ですね
欠かせない知識
はやっぱり知らないとねはい進みます
まぁこれ読むだけにします生きること
皆生きているから
何をすれば良い
命をつなぐために何が必要かという二つの
問題に興味を抱く
人間考えたらそれだけでしょう
生きていることはもう気にしない
どうすればいい
何すればもう
命が繋ぎますかねこれから生きるために私
はどうすればいいかということだけしか
考えてないんですどんな仕事をすればいい
とか
ねどんな地方に住めばいいとか
ねしかし人々は学ばない項目あるんですよ
これ学んでくださいと
生きるとは何と
どうすれば生きられますかではなくて生き
るって何
なぜ何としてでも生きていきたい
そうでしょうみんな
何としてでも生きてきたんですあれって何
ですかと勉強してください
3生きることの
総合的な
価値があるんですかと何か生きていて
良かったって何か価値がある得られますか
とそれは本当に嘘でみんなごまかしている
んです
仏教は命の仕組みを教えていますそこで
仏教から
ぶったっての師匠だから
命の仕組みを学んでくださいこれブッダ
しか教えてないんです
ヒンドゥー教に入っちゃうとチャッカラは
どう開発するのかとかねコンビニはどう
どうするのそんな神秘的宗教的にイカ顔的
なものばっかりしゃべるんです
客観的科学的に
命のことを教えてないんです
そこで仏教は人生の総合的な価値生きる
ことであなた得る価値がありますよと教え
てます何ですかね
生まれる時もこうです生きている時の
苦しいんです死ぬときでも苦しいんですだ
から全体的なあなたの総合
我流はこうですよ
勇気が人間にないんです
人間が頭バイアスだらけで
あるいは食う
虚しい
your
ということです
あなた何やってきちゃっても全て
捨てて
あれは毎日何でこんなに生きてること不満
が入っているんです
それには明確に何で不満があるのかとかね
それはまぁ
仏教で説明全ての物事は無常です無常って
いうのはこの量子力学的に物はずっと並み
ですよあるわけじゃないんです
波って変化しますから
ねだからこの波は安定ということはなら
ないん
ですだからずっと不安なんです
で不安は不満になるんです
関わると
どのように生きれば人格向上できるのか
どうすれば生きる苦しみから
脱出できるのか
これから人間なら誰でも学ぶべき知識です
これはエッセンシャルの
歴史仏教はエッセンシャルの歴史だけ教え
ているんです
はっきりお釈迦様言うんです私はたくさん
喋ってますけど
エッセンシャルの率だけやと知っている
ことは
膨大にありますよ
これらは人間なら誰なの知識ですこの知識
がある人は
理性的に生きるんですこの命の仕組み知っ
たらもう理性的に生きられます
あのバイアスがほとんど
邪魔しないん
ですすごい面白いんでしょう
この
五州のことやら因果法則やらね心やる
貪瞋痴で生きているんだとか
ね命っていうのは瞬間の出来事でこの
波長の組み合わせで
成り立つものじゃないやとかね
分かると
うまくいきましょう人生は
考古学知らなくても
歴史学者でなくても
はい次に行きます
そこで問題
知識にもバイアスがあるん
です
人は感情に導かれて知識を求めるので
激しいバイアスがありますあの
エッセンシャルの歴史ではないんです
我々は普通の
求めるでしょう
ちっちゃいというからも知識
求めるんですよあれはもうバイアスでね
感情があるんだからね
子供達にでも学びたいものがあるんですね
大嫌いなあれはやりたくないというものも
ありますね
だから知識ってそんなもんですよ全然
バイアスあります
それで一番おかしいことは人間知識に執着
するん
これ変です
自分知っていることで執着する
だって知識って
膨大でしょう
自分知ってるのほんのわずかでしょう
それもみるみるうちに変わるでしょう
自分知った知識より優れた知識が他の人
開発しているんです自分がそれで知らない
何のに自分の知識に
執着する
人は車に執着してもいいん
ですあの服に執着してもいいんです
なぜならば問題は起きません
私はこの車すごく大好きよと言ったっても
世の中他の車あることを知っているし車の
寿命年齢も知っているし
別にそんな大きい問題じゃないん
です服に執着したっても
何年生きられるかどうかあれこれ知って
ますから
しかしややこしいの知識に対する
執着それだけ捨てた方がいいん
です愛のおじさいのではダメなんです
Ihave3番レストランリンリンオフ
まるまるなんです
俺は
経験の何々ものかとか
ね言っちゃうと知識執着なんです
今一人が見えたんだからその人の
私は経験な編集者やと思ったら知識に
対する執着なんです
私は東大の教授だと
別に普通のおっさんでしょうと言ってみて
くださいその時
は普通の
何であれでなんか人を差別して
人を踏みつけて
権威を出して
恥ずかしくても
たまらんでしょう
知識って
何か現れて消えるものなんでしょう
虹を見てこの
虹が私の虹だとか
ね色んなバカなことでしょう
それで世の中でこの例えばこの知識人の
世界でね大学みたいなね色んな
こういう優れた
技術持っている会社とかねそういうところ
で
かなり人間関係が
ねおかしくなるんでみんな例えばすごい
行動な技術使っている会社とかは
ものすごく優れたエンジニアたちが仕事し
ています
だからお互いに自分の能力を誇示して
威張っているんだから
雰囲気が悪いよ
明るくないんです
緊張するん
で何でか分からない例えば学会とか発表会
とかねなんで緊張するんですか
知識に対する
執着なんです
知識を得た結果
頑固な人間になってしまいますですから
苦労して習得した即世間的な知識も
汚染されて自分と他人の役に立たなくなり
ますこの知識に執着しちゃうとその知識が
役に立たなくなります
立派な知識人で
すごく
頑固じゃない優しい人間になると私たちは
先生こういう問題で
助けてくださいと
言うでしょう
にいくらあの人はもう専門家で
プロデューサー
しない方がいいとか
喋れない方がいいや
ということになるんですだから人は自分の
知識に執着することであの知識を人類の
ために
活かすことすらできなくなるんです
我々には現在
原子爆弾作る空母を作るエンジニアたち
しかいなくなっちゃったんです
バイオケミカルパン作る
すごい頭がいい連中よ
場所を
作っちゃう場合はね生物学的兵器とかね
馬鹿にできませんよ
だから
知識ってそんなもんですだから
エッセンシャルの歴史だけ取ってください
この
能力はどんな人間にもある
皆様数学学ぶ
経済学を学ぶ生産使ってないん
です誰もアクセスしない
脳みそのところがあるんです
そこを使って仏教の知識を教えているん
です
時々すごい
科学とか偉人やとかね超エリートの人々が
学んで学んで学んでまくったところで何と
か空を感じるんです
脳みその中で
それで仏教に入っちゃうん
です
スリランカで若い何人かいるんですよ会社
で重役やっていて
ものすごい小学生でエンジニアで
全部止めて出家して
それで
仏教喋りますけどその物の見事に分かり
やすくしゃべるんです
買ってこんなことできたと知った言葉も
言わない
だから
エッセンシャルの歴史という仏教が教える
命の科学それはこの数学学ぶところを言語
学を学ぶところいらない別に普段使わない
セクション使うん
ですはい
では知識のバイアスはサーッと早く行き
ます
1から4までこのカラーという最高の人々
の教えた教えなんですよこれが
説明するとすごい時間かかる大変な作業
ですけど
軽々しく名前で1まぁあのこの日本語学
調べて出した水門でしたっけね伝説でも
風説などを避ける
的にもありますけど何か知る場合は
みんなそう言っている
伝統的にそういう言い伝えだよとだから
正しいに決まっているんだよとあんな態度
やめてくださいと
伝説であってもいいやそんなのはとだから
私は言ったでしょう私は東大の教授だと
ただおっさんに見えますけどという調子で
いいん
ですだから東大を偉いところやということ
伝説でしょう
これは普通はこのオーロラジーセンという
学ぶ時は人から聞いて学ぶということあり
ますから
のことですね
師匠橙の知識
例えば
ヒンドゥー教のレーザー
本に書かなかったんです
たくさんあります
師匠は唱える弟子が
覚えて暗記する
だからでそれは事実へと認めるなよと二番
目はパランパラパラントの相続なんか
わからない大体
伝わってくる
知識能力大体
伝わっているからと言って事実という保証
じゃないんです
3番目まぁ生き嫌い
とりあえず
オフセット
噂の
あんた知っているまぁこうなってだったら
どうやって噂
頼ったり
ニュースに頼ったり
ネットでやりましたよ
とだから何と
本当にネットで面倒くさいんですよ
事実することは難しい難しい
4番目とかサンタだねこれは
今日でしたっけね
晴天などテキストになっている知識と
テレビで映画とか見るとねなんかすごい
分厚い本持ってきて誰の聖書ですけどね
あれ見た目が内容は大したことないんだ
から
読んでみたら
だから
仏教聖典にも聖典と言いますよ
仏教正典だからはい信じますやめて
ちょうだい
とだからそういうのは我々のバイアスなん
ですよ
配色にしますまだたくさん10までやり
ます
5番目はまぁたった兵と
いわゆる
読めないこれはコピーペーしたんだけどね
理論
守備論
まあロジックですね
ロジクの場合は2種類あります
6番目は方法
次は
これはロジクの場合はこのリダっていう
ロジック
という2つの終わりますねあの一応
日本語訳をコピペしました
読めません
英語で機能法
だからロジックでロジック好きな人は
路地で考えるんですこれ真理に達しません
よで7番目
マーカー
何か考えてみたら人もこういうこの人
やっぱりこうでしょうねやっぱりこの人
言っていることは本当でしょうねとかね
ただ雰囲気で決める
雰囲気で決めるものは結構ありますねそれ
もバイアスです
これプロヴァバビリティということですね
可能性
8番目は関係
や自分が持っている哲学自分が持っている
信仰
自分の生き方
自分の人生論に
合う
だったら
それを信じましょう
やめなさいと
こんなのはバイアスだよと
で最後の2つ
ねバブルパターン
有能な外見によるなかれと
なんです
ね
2つです
こういうのは私若い頃に二十歳頃研究する
ところだから今全部忘れちゃってねだから
タッチするのは怖いんですどこまで行くか
分からないん
です
と英語で言えばねこちらで9番目は
ポシェビリティ
で日本語訳した方々はそこまで
哲学的に経典調べてないんだからまぁ
適当な役を出してはいるんですだからそこ
で
プレゼンテーション見事
感動的に
プレゼントする
それでみんな
信じちゃいますね
10番目
まぁ様のガルこれははっきりお釈迦様が
自分に言っているんです
仏教はすごいところそこなんですこの
カーラーマ系の人々に
行ったことない私がすっごい
尊敬されている
師匠だから
だからと言って鵜呑みにするなよ
この
写門が我々の死だという
理由による流れと
偉大なるブッダの教えだからという
理由でも
鵜呑みにしてはならないんですねそこで
我々には
ニューヨーク大学の教授
去年のノベル賞を取った
ノベルロッド
で
改めて
信じちゃうでしょう
だから大体ね
読むときでもどんな大学でどんな形状で
どこで生まれて何者かと見てそれがこの本
なら
読んでもいいと決めるでしょう
だから
有名な人だから
有名な大学出たからと言って内容は信頼
できることもないんです
そういう
権威ですねその場合は
使ってはいけないんです
どうですかね知識の場合は10
項目のバイアスがあるんです
かなりやられますよ例えば私でも結構理論
使っちゃいますよ
でインド系だからね
でも
路地では真理には達しません
はいそういうことで10項目のバイアスが
あります知識にとって次に行きます
そこで
絡むさんに言うんで生き方自分で決め
てよう
釈迦様にブッダ言うからやるなよ
と一人一人が自分で生きているでしょう
だから仏教は宗教じゃなくて逆なんですね
安定のなん
です自分で行きなさいよ
ブッダが言ったから
仏典に書いてあるからとかね
奴隷じゃないんだから
そこで生きる場合は生きるとは
真空への行為です
ね行為することですだからエッセンシャル
の歴史それが必要です生きるとは真空への
行為することですこの
信仰の行為が
感情に汚れているとしましょう
感情1番目は
貪欲
貪欲の感情に刺激される
信仰への行為は
前科悪化自分で決めて
だから一人が考えるん
で
貪欲で何かやったらこれ
成功ですかね
姿勢ある人は悪行為だと分かるんです
貪欲で良い行為はできません
貪欲があったら人を持っているものを奪う
ことはできます
ごまかして取ることはできますけど自分
持っているものも上手を持ってくださいと
人を助けることできない
ねだから
布団
貪欲がない心は古い
欲がないその時の行為は前科開くか
当然その時は善であると
絡むさん達が言ったんでだったらやって
くださいよと
貪欲の行為は悪になるんだからこれは自分
たちでやめたほうがいいでしょうに次は
真理です
ね真偽の感情で
やる
信仰への行為は全角か
不信怒りのない心で行う
信仰への行為が前科開くかそれで分かる
でしょう何が前何があるかと
全部選びなさいと言わなくなってもね自分
で選んでくださいよ
人殺すか助けるか
と私が言う必要ない人殺さない助けて
くださいと
お前言うから助けますように
囲われる
ねだから人は自由で人を助ける
人を馬鹿にしないなぜならばそれは私の
怒りです
で血の場合も同じく
無口な人がやることは
禅ですかじゃあ
愚痴がない無知がない人は
淵の人やっていることはね理性がある人
やっていることは全然決まっている
そういう風にどう生きるかということは
一人一人が自分でフリーで考えてください
それに邪魔するんだよと
宗教の教え
伝統的な教え
文化的な言い伝え
邪魔するんだよ
論理的なアプローチ
いらんがそんなの
言って
正しくこのエッセンシャルの得る方法と
正しく生きる方法がお釈迦様が
指令しないで教えたんです
はいこんなもんで終わると思いますね
終わり
で理性の生き方
このように自ら判断して自分の自由
意志で生きてみるならばそれが
理性的な生き方になります
必ず
能力と人格が向上します
信じられない人間になります
幸福な生き方が現れますみんな本当に何で
不幸かと
理解できないんですよ何のことの幸福に
生きられるの
に
完成すると
貪瞋痴の3つなくすことね
解脱よりも達します
これで全部プログラム終わりということに
なりますはいそういう風に
理性的に生きるとはそういうことでかなり
役に立つ役に立たないことをたくさん言い
ましたけどたまたま役に立つこともあった
と思いますね最低ね生きるとは
間違いの連続ですということでも理解して
リラックスしてでもだからと言って間違い
少なくしようではないか
と4つのバイアスから
心を清らかにして生きてみてくださいどう
もありがとうございます
[拍手]
はい
祈願です
ドッカーン
[音楽]
にそうか
本当サン
の
苦しんで
悩む生命が苦しみもなく
恐れて悩む生命が
恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみもなく一切の
生命が安穏でありますようにサードサード
サードはいどうもありがとうございます
ありがとうございました次回の放送
いただきます
教会ホームページ等でお知らせいたします
のでぜひまたご予約の方でございますこれ
から
撤収作業に入りますが皆さん
もう一度お手元の方を確認いただきまして
携帯電話とお忘れ物のプロジェクトで
ございますので
ご確認の絵を書いて
くださいそれではどうもありがとうござい
ました
では自分の瞑想いたします
私は